online magic Thank You NICU thank you
for having me here so today I would like
to tell you about some recent progress
from the theoretical computer science
community on coming up with new online
matching model where the key motivating
example is for the right sharing
application so before I start I would
like to make a disclaimer because I'm
from the theoretical computer science
community so when we make modeling
choices we tend to abstract away many
aspects of the problem that you may deem
kind of relevant or even important in
the real application but at the end of
the day we try to keep a abstract
combinatorial or algorithmic problem
that's kind of more general than right
sharing itself so let me start by
reviewing the classic online bipartite
matching problem proposed by astronomers
Ronnie which I will refer to as the kbv
model so in this problem we're going to
imagine there's a bipartite graph and
one side of the vertices let's say the
left hand side are known to the
algorithm at the very beginning and
we're going to call them the offline
vertices and then the vertices from the
other side will arrive one at a time so
on the arrival of each of these online
verdicts these edges incident to it are
reviewed to the algorithm and the
algorithm must immediately decide how to
match this online vertex to one of the
offline neighbor so for example let's
say I match it to the second one it's
arrived once again I match it to the
second available neighbor that third one
comes match to the second available
neighbor and so on and so forth so later
on there might be some vertices that
arrive and has no available neighbor the
point is that these online decisions are
irrevocable in the sense that I can all
kind of upon seeing this vertex I cannot
match it to this one and then revoke
this decision
we match this one to it another offline
neighbor that's not allowed so at the
end of the day we're trying to maximize
the number of edges that we managed to
match and in online algorithm we're
going to compare the objective to the
optimal achievable in the offline
setting knowing the inhye bipartite
graph and doing the optimization problem
exactly so in this case our in hindsight
we will realize that okay that actually
exists the perfect matching between the
left hand side the right hand side so
the ratio here would be 3 over 5 or 0.6
so in this problem there's a very simple
greedy algorithm I just match each
online vertex to an arbitrary unmatched
neighbor and we can show that it is a
point 5 competitive in the sense that
I've at least get a cardinality that is
at least a point 5 times the maximum
cardinality matching in hindsight
so the question asked back then almost
three decades ago is that can we do
better than point five so kvv show a
very elegant algorithm called ranking so
it works as follows at very beginning
I'm going to choose a random ordering or
random ranking over all the offline
vertices so let's say I assign number
one to five to the offline vertices and
the smaller the number the higher the
priority so on the arrival of each
online vertex I'm going to match it to
the unmatched neighbor with the highest
or smallest rank in this case so for
example the first one it has three
neighbors with rank three four and five
so I'm going to match it to the rank
three neighbor the point is when the
second vertex arrived I'm going to stick
with the same ranking I'm not going to
redraw this ranking every single time
I'm gonna stick with the same ranking so
this ranking actually introduced some
correlation over the randomness or the
random position across different online
versus okay so at the end of the day if
I stick with this ranking then I will
manage to match four vertices and what
they show is that if you use this very
elegant ranking algorithm then you can
do better than point five and in fact
you can do one minus one over e
competitive which is roughly 63 percent
compared to the offline optimal in
hindsight and this is the best you can
do in this online bipartite matching
okay so um we have a online matching
model let's try to think about whether
we can use it to capture the
ride-sharing law problem in the Russian
problem I argue there are at least two
aspects that are fail that failed to be
captured by this online bipartite
matching problem in Russia ring I'm
going to consider a bunch of right
requests submitting to the platform and
into the view I can model each right
request as the vertex and then put an
edge between them if these pair of
vertex can be matched together in the
sense that their pickup location and the
destination are reasonably close with
respectfully and also kind of the
requests are submitted to the system at
roughly the same time they have bit it's
not like one request somewhere in the
morning the other somebody in the
evening okay if you think about it this
is not necessarily a bipartite graph
right and second of all model the
problem like that all the vertices will
arrive online there's no such thing as
offline verdicts that are given to the
algorithm beforehand
okay so I'm I'm trying to model the
matching problem of pairing different
write requests I'm not trying to pair
model the part where I'm match right
requests with drivers if you're
traveling model pairing request with
drivers it would be more or less than a
paragraph but for Rachelle ring
it's not about paragraph okay so in the
last few years there have been a number
of papers trying to come up with more
general online matching model that will
allow us to capture general graphs and
allow over desist you're right on line
so that we can actually study Russian
problem from the online matching
perspective so I'm going to cover to
work one by myself
it's called fully online matching we
have like two papers in the last few
years with in collaboration with a bunch
of students from the from a computer
science department so as I mentioned
there are a few aspects right one is
that the graph is not bipartite the
other is all the verses right online so
as a starter let me only focus on the
part where all vertices arrive online
but keeping the graph to be R by
paragraph for now so you put it in the
context imagine you're running a real as
the agency that you're trying to match
penance with LAN loads so while the
tenants and landlords both arrive online
each specifies certain criterias of what
kind of cannons or what kind of
apartments they're looking for and if
they mutually satisfy each other's
requirement then potentially you can
match them and we're going to say that
okay there's edge between them now at
some point one of the landlord we say
okay really by this time I want my
apartment TV you know rent it out in the
market so that's kind of the latest
moment where the agency can match this
this apartment of this landlord to one
of the potential tenant and once I make
that decision this is permanent
I cannot revoke it and later on it may
be that okay this is this is a tenant I
really need to move in - let's say Bay
Area
next week I cannot wait any longer so at
that time I also need you immediately
match these ten into one of the landlord
okay so you can see this is clearly a
matching problem with the online nature
and this is a bipartite matching but
once again all the vertices will be
arriving online cannot be captured by
the classic kbv model that I just
explained
so here's the model that we come up with
trying to capture the scenario both of
the this matching tenant-landlord
and also the right sharing problem again
there's some underlying graph and I'm
going to have two kinds of time steps
the first kind is the arrival of some
vertex V and at that time just like in
the kV model I'm going to able to see
all the edges between this new vertex V
and its neighbors that have already
arrived there could be some neighbors
that were arrived in the future I will
not be able to see those edges the
second kind of time step would be the
deadline of some vertex and basically
that's the last moment that you can make
a matching decision about this vertex
after that this vertex is gone is out of
the market
and I'm going to assume that all the
neighbors of V arrived before V stat
line so in other words there could be a
edge between two vertices only if the
time window defined by this a rifle and
that line of the vertex have overlap yes
that's a very good question the
algorithm that we are going to talk
about do not need that information but
for the application that we talked about
in might make sense to assume that you
know that that line and I think it's an
interesting question whether the
algorithm can make use of that
information to have better performance
for the algorithm that I'm going to
introduce next we're not going to need
that information okay
but I do assume that at the deadline
kind of the V announced okay today is my
deadline and then the algorithm will has
one last chance to make the online
decision so it's not like at the
deadline
okay the algorithm lose the the vertex
forever without having a chance to make
the having one last chance to make a
matching decision about a vertex for now
you can imagine it's a bipartite because
of the tenon and Leno
but also you can from the description
here well there's no reason that we
restrict ourselves by paragraph because
the whole description does not rely on
the fact that the graph is bipartite
so I'm coming back to this assumption
this assumption may sound restrictive at
the first glance but actually it's quite
natural if you think about it from the
actual scenario that were chattin
capture well in the right sharing model
I'm not going to be able to match a
right request in the morning with
request in the evening so I'm not going
to be able to right match a tenant who's
looking for an apartment in January with
a apartment that's available in May
right so this overlapping high window
assumption is actually quite natural in
the application and also even with this
assumption it's a strict generalization
of the kbv model now recall k-v model we
have offline vertices and online
vertices right just imagine all the
offline vertices are super patient they
arrive at the very beginning and have
that line at the very end and online
vertices are super impatient they
arrived on day 1 and then you know have
to deadline the next day right so then
it can be captured in this fully online
model with appropriate choices of
arrival and deadline
now again for the ride sharing platform
example it's the same deal okay except
that the underlying graph is no longer
bipartite again each request has arrival
time and a deadline and I compare match
a pair of requests if again the pickup
location and destination are compatible
and also the active time window overlaps
but abstractly I can still model with
this one a fully online matching model
that I described in the previous slide
okay so basically I have a new on a
matching problem and it is not too
difficult to show that the simple greedy
oven base achill e whenever you have a
new verdicts you if there's a available
neighbor you kind of match it to a
arbitrary available neighbor that's you
at 0.5 compared out with them meaning
that you keep at least 0.5 of the
maximum cardinality compared to the up
on match in hindsight now on the other
hand as I mentioned this strictly
generalized the kvv model right and in
the kvv model 1 minus 1 over e is the
magic number there's a ranking I
wouldn't achieve this number and it is
known that no algorithm can do better so
basically I cannot hope to beat this one
minus 1 over your number and I can
cheerily get point 5 so the question is
once again can we do better than 0.5 can
we get all the way to 1 minus 1 over e
or is this somewhere in the middle if
that's somewhere in the middle what
would be the algorithm and what would be
that magic number that's the kind of
question that we asked yes
how the algorithm actually right so you
propose a met and people see so you did
the match is final and that's it um so
from for for this talk we are
considering kind of a just a algorithmic
aspect of the problem so there's no game
theoretic behavior strategic behavior of
these potential riders that you are
decimating the requests so the algorithm
has full power to dictate who is going
to pair with whom okay so all we care
about is that suppose you have this full
power what should be the algorithm that
you will use in this online
decision-making process so that you can
maximize the number of successes for
matching so in this case is just that
like the number of edges that you
managed to match but because you're
making this decision online so you
cannot expect you somehow be kind of
have out getting the maximum cardinality
in hindsight right because that that's
kind of the information cost that you
pay because you're you're making partial
decisions without seeing the big picture
so coming back to let me come back to
this very like the kvv model just to
there's no there's no preferences so
again like this example right at the
time at the time that this vertex
arrived
I immediately need to match to one of
the neighbor without seeing okay what
might be happy what might happen in the
rest of the graph in the future and
later on I cannot kind of regret a
previous matching match decision and
revoke it in light of new information
that's not allowed like once I dispatch
a driver to pick up these Cube despair
passengers I cannot revoke the decision
and do it
yes yes yes
I don't it's a complete graph then yes I
agree that you should be able to but
there are restrictions right like in
right sharing the you know pick up
occasion and destination should be
reasonably close and so on examples
where the best solution is a perfect
match right right right right and every
time your algorithm reaches if it's the
predicted one point five of the best on
the on the average okay so okay that
yeah good worst-case analysis it's the
focus of this talk also a worst-case
expectation over the randomness of the
algorithm but worst case over potential
instances
the fast-forward
okay so again this is kind of the
picture that we have in mind so let me
first show you the main results just
using the same picture I'm going to
explain from left to right the the
clinical part that I'm going to cover in
this talk at least at high level is that
you can still use the ranking algorithm
with appropriate impotent implementation
in the fully online matching model to
beat point five like this number is not
super important because I'm pretty sure
it's not the right magic number but the
conceptual message that you can still
reuse ranking to be 0.5 should be the
takeaway yes I mean ranking is still
kind I don't know what you mean by
first-come first they arrive in time and
all the algorithm are kind of doing the
matching in a kind of a first come first
that line first manner the problem is
how are you going to do that choose
which available neighbor that you're
going to match it to okay and I think
that the key inside or key idea behind
ranking is this very subtle way of
introducing a consistent like rank over
all the vertices and you stick with the
same rank throughout the whole process
which introduced correlation in a very
subtle way and that somehow allows you
to be 2.5 I should also mention that if
you just do like draw a new ranking
every single round that will not be
point 5 in the worst case analysis okay
so it's very important that you have
this very subtle way of introducing
randomness okay so once again meeting
point 5 it is the conception message
don't bother with this number this is
for general graph even for general graph
and in the fully online matching model
you can still use ranking to be point 5
okay and if I restrict the attention our
attention to bipartite graph then we
understand quite a bit better we
actually are able to capture the right
magic number for the algorithm for
ranking algorithm and it is this roughly
point five six seven which is called a
combing a constant but this is tight for
ranking out with them on by background
sorry
yes it's the solution of e to the X
minus one equals x if I remember
correctly but I may be wrong by like
some of the cons to might be off but but
something like that yeah
okay what a feeling I'm not quite
important for this audience but like
what a feeling is kind of a fractional
relaxation of the air with for the
fractional reacts ation of the problem
oftentimes intercom designs we kind of
consider these fractional problems as
kind of an intermediate step for getting
to the right solution so for what a
feeling we also characterize the the
right number which is like human is
square root of Q which is this number
and this number is smaller than 1 minus
1 we even though just by a tiny bit it
just showed that it doesn't matter how
smart your algorithm is in this more
general model you are not going to be
able to get to 1 minus 1 over EE so in
this sense it's strictly harder than the
kbp model yes I have to check whether it
is possible to kind of extend the result
you knowing it that I'm sure how do you
know the answer like okay so so we can
check offline about that but for now
let's just say that okay assume that you
don't know the deadline then you cannot
be like you cannot get all the way to
unless one of you this one no it's
actually a algorithm that like this this
bound holds even for fraction algorithm
and for fraction algorithm basically you
don't need to like go through a lemma
it's because it's a for watching out
with them you can kind of assume without
loss that it's a it's missing
it's it's it's kind of constructing
something similar to this upper triangle
graph plus some extra gadget and I have
to admit that I do not have a strong
intuition of why that context that will
work out of then that like if you do the
calculation it is strictly smaller than
one minus one over you yeah it's a cross
or algorithm it's arbitrary fractional
algorithm cannot beat cannot get to one
minus one over ye and therefore like
integral with them this is only tight
for the water feeling algorithm and
actually at the end of the talk I should
also mention some work-in-progress
showing that there's actually a reason
to believe that for the fully online
matching problem we should actually move
beyond ranking and what the feeling
there's some aspects of the problem that
that these ti wouldn't fail to capture
but I will leave it to the end when
after i I do not know the answer yeah I
I do not know the answer yeah it should
be no III believe it should be lower but
I do not know any like good technique
for proving that that would that will
not help in the worst-case analysis and
in fact all those examples that we
construct you you can easily scale the
instance to
Oh
agents are infinitely lived but in that
case you can always wait until the very
end to make the make me do the
optimization in in the offline setting
so even even even now the algorithm that
we consider here kind of are lazy in the
sense that always wait until some vertex
reached the deadline before I make the
matching decision about that vertex for
the ranking I want to feel like
algorithm I always wait and also like
any algorithm can be interpreted in a
way that you only make those decision at
the end but that does not say that like
for the right algorithm the most natural
interpretation should wait that that I
yeah and actually again some of the
working progress we make use of
algorithm that makes some immediate
decision so no we are actually
considering up Tory graph here
so once again if you are willing to make
extra assumption maybe you can get away
with stronger results and in fact later
on I'm going to also talk about much
related model by a different group of
researcher that kind of make extra
assumption which allow them to have
extra power I'm going to get that in the
like second part of the talk
okay so let me try to
once again like let me try to explain
what ranking is you know generalize to
this problem where I have like all the
vertices arrived online and also in a
general graph I have to pick a random
permutation or random ranking over all
the vertices and then whenever a vertex
reached a deadline I'm going to look at
all the available neighbors that has not
been matched yet and match find the one
with the highest rank or smallest ring
actually one of the first question that
you may ask is that can we actually
implement this problem because this is
an online problem right at the beginning
I don't even know all the vertices so
how am I supposed to pick a random
permutation over all the vertices it's a
small trick that actually is kind of
folklore among the on an algorithm
community is that one way to realize
this random permutation is that you draw
random number let's say uniform between
0 and 1 for every single vertex and then
just you might deduce the ranking based
on that random number right but if you
use that interpretation you can actually
draw this random number on the fly so
for when whenever a new vertex arrive
you can you draw a number Y yrv let's
say uniformly within 0 & 1 and use that
number to induce the Sun to deduce these
are random ranking ok and again I want
to stress that like the small that this
number is the high the priority just
because like the integral version Rank 1
it has highest priority
okay so um I think I should speed up a
little bit so let me go through a
analysis of the ranking algorithm which
is kind of a gainsharing
argument so imagine that whenever a new
vertex arrived and a match happen I'm
going to imagine that the algorithm get
one unit of game because I get one new
edge and I'm going to split this one
unit of game between the two endpoints
of the edge so for now let's imagine
that I just do it very naively like one
half goes to this vertex and one half
goes to this vertex that's the one so
forth okay now I'd like to argue that
the analysis can go as follows now if I
want to counter how many edges then I
wouldn't manage to take well since I
just split the game I'm between the
endpoints right so it suffices to just
sum over all the vertices and see how
much gain that each vertex gets and that
should equal to the number of edges that
I wouldn't get according to this game
sharing process now another way of
counting like summing over all the
vertices would be just to look at all
the edges in the optimal matching in
hindsight and for each edge I sum over
the game of the two endpoints because
it's a matching I'm going to count each
vertex at most once
now it just boils down to showing that
for each edge the total gain of the two
end points some to at least eat the
desirable comparative ratio in this case
let's say point five because I'm using a
very naive gain splitting splitting
process and that's easy to see because
what by the greedy nature of the
algorithm I'm never going to leave both
end points of a edge unmatched
otherwise when the right-hand side
verdicts arrive you know it has a match
neighbor so I should pick at least one
of the neighbors you match it right I
will never leave two end points of this
of an actual match and as long as one of
the end point get matched while the game
should be 0.5 at least so this will give
a point 5 comparative analysis now if
you want to get beyond that that you
need the most
the smarter or game sharing process in
particular in the kbv model I'm going to
let the offline versus get a share that
depends on its rank the random rank that
I draw at the beginning and for some
appropriate chosen function G and the
online vertex get the rest of this year
now to generalize this to the fully
online matching model the first thing is
ha the first thing that we need to do is
to find kind of counterparts for offline
online vertices because remember in the
Foley on a matching model there's no
such thing as offline vertices all the
vertices are online so for that we
introduced the concept of active and
passive verdicts so if a match happens
between Q versus U and V let's say I use
that line in that record that the the
algorithm is lazy right I I will make
this decision and only at 1 the deadline
of one of the two endpoints whichever is
earlier so if I make the matched happen
I'd use that line which means that use
that lines earlier than these deadlines
so I'm going to call for this edge U is
the active vertex and biess the passive
vertex so again like coming to the rule
as the example
then for the first match it's the
landlord's deadline so the landlord will
be the active vertex and the talent will
be the passive vertex and the second
match happens when at the tenants
deadline so that tenant can be directed
verdicts and the landlord would be the
passive vertex now the point here is
that the active vertex will play a row
that's similar to the online vertex in
the kvv model in the sense that what it
is it is the active vertex who look
around its neighborhood and see what are
the available neighbor and I kind of
actively pick one of them and decide
which one so I'm going to call that
active vertex to play a similar role as
online vertex and the passive vertex D
plays in a row of offline verdicts and
likewise in the gain splitting process
I'm going to split the game based on the
rank of the passive vertex of the edge
okay so now this part of the argument
may be very familiar to those of you who
have worked on on I imagine but I'm
going to go through it anyway so the
analysis relaxed on some kind of a so
okay so let me actually slow down here
so I'm going to zoom in on a particular
edge UV and try to analyze what's the
total gain that you and B get in
expectation in the whole process over
the randomness of the out with it
um and you simplify the analysis I'm
going to actually fix the rank of all
the other vertices okay and then you can
imagine that as V V is the passive
vertex here
so as B's rank gets better and better
this let's analyze how does the matching
changes what is if V is kind of super
unpopular then we imagine that these
unmatched are even at use that line
because it's super unpopular no one's
going to pick V right now if V gets
above certain threshold and become
popular enough then V will be passively
match or pegged by some other vertex
before use that line
so the point here is that in that case I
can argue that you will be at least
match to your verdicts with rank equal
to this theta throughout the whole
process and the reason is that well if
use matching for this interval it's very
easy to see because well you have a
available neighbor that could be as good
as having rank theater but still you do
not choose this neighbor right that can
happen only because you have an outside
option that is at least as good have as
having rank equal to theta if B gets
popular then what happened is that it
would trigger some kind of a alternating
path meaning that okay maybe we get
popular some vertex decided to pick V
and then that opens up it's a regional
matched neighbor and some other word has
get trigger to pick that neighbor and so
on and so forth and all the vertices on
the right hand side gets better because
they change their matching decision in
light of a new opportunity and new
neighbor
and in the by paragraph U is always on
the right-hand side and that's why you
always gets better now this is the key
property that we used in the bipartite
matching case I'm going to jump to the
general case to argue that in the
general graph I can no longer claim that
I can only claim that when these rank
gets better and becomes smaller than
this threshold Sita U is still at least
as good as matching to your vertex with
rank theta and the reason is very simple
right because the argument that I just
gave you is that okay when V gets better
it triggers the alternating path and all
the vertices on the right hands of this
alternating path get better and on the
bipartite case you for sure who appear
on the right-hand side but in the
general graph you could appear on the
left-hand side and in the worst case
scenario you could appear at the end of
this alternating path meaning that it
may change from being matched to be an
unmatched
okay so and it turns out this this is
actually the crux of the analysis for
the general case if I just used the old
case splitting argument then it doesn't
matter how how smart you choose this
case split in function G you cannot bid
0.5 so I need some new ideas some new
argument in the analysis I'm just going
to just jump to the new gain splitting
feature here
the new concept we introduced here is
the victim and conversation so it's kind
of structural inside that whenever a
pair of verdicts U and V get into
trouble in the analysis in the sense
that you cannot get better than point
five using the old analysis there's
always some reason for that in
particular we always find some vertex W
that is responsible for the misery of
this pair of verdicts in particular for
every vertex W I'm going to call another
vertex V as the victim of W if the two
conditions of all our holds first of all
these are match neighbor of W meaning
that when W make a decision that we
could have picked V but double choose
not you and the second condition is that
if I take W away from the graph and
rerun the whole algorithm with the same
rank V will become matched if this
condition happened am Concordat W V is a
victim of W and I'm going to kind of
send a portion of the game received by W
to V as a conversation now I'm running
out of time so I'm not going to go
through the detailed analysis but this
is kind of the key new ingredient in the
analysis that we introduced to make it
possible to to analyze the general graph
so let me quickly go through a much
related model are introduced by another
group of researcher at slack as ledger
and suburi from stanford bert and our
Jayla from MIT and daughter and shirley
from lift and it appearing easy this
year which is a merger of three
manuscripts so the model is very very
similar to the one that I explained
except for the blue parts so in a way it
kind of makes extra assumption but also
get extra power the extra assumption
that I make is that the time window
which is that the length of time you
know which is defined by the difference
between the deadline and the rival time
is fixed
equivalently you can imagine this is
just a 500 order like the request
arrived earlier we also leave the system
earlier now in the right sharing example
this assumption action makes a lot of
sense now by making this assumption the
actual power that they get is that they
are able to handle the edge weighted
case of the problem meaning that
different edges may carry different
values and some edges let's say pair
requests that have like longer distance
have Q value to the system and they are
able to model that and still be able to
get out with them with non-trivial
compare ratio and the ratio that they
get of because it's a edge weighted case
it's much smaller so that what they show
is that there is a algorithm for the
edge weighted case that is at least a
quarter competitive and no algorithm can
get better than 0.5 in the activated
case and also they also consider a
variation where they assume some kind of
randomness in the graph in the sense of
random arrival and they guess something
slightly better than 1/4 ok so I believe
I can show the main idea of their
algorithm in five minutes which so it
works as follow actually I'm going to
present kind of a dumb more version of
the algorithm which will not like it a
quarter but that capture kind of the key
idea of their algorithm which is rely on
a reduction to the kvv model so suppose
this is the underlying graph and they
arrive in the order of 1 2 3 4 5 6 and
also like 1 will leave right after 3
arrive forwardly who will leave right
after 4 right and so on so the algorithm
will first randomly place each vertex on
an imaginary by paragraph and each
vertex will be placed on the left or
right with equal probability
independently so let's say it turns out
that one tooth 5 up here on the left and
3 4 6 appear on the right
okay now I also need to define which
subset of edges will be kept in this
imaginary bipartite graph and I'm going
to keep my edge if the vertex with the
earlier that line appear on the left and
the vertex with the later that line
appear on the right now in this case the
edge between 1 & 2 will not be kept
because they are both on the left the
edge between 3 & 1 & 2 will be kept
because 1 & 2 are arrived earlier but
the edge between 3 & 4 & 5 will not be
kept because voice on the same side and
5 actually arrive later than 3 so even
though this look like a edge across to
side it wouldn't will not be kept in
this reduction
now one arrived you arrived we arrived
in the imaginary part I graph
I would imagine three as an online
vertex with two neighbors
now I've just run the greedy out with
them let's say I match three to two and
I'm going to do the same thing in the
like the general graph
similarly when four arrived well in the
imaginary paragraph it has only one
neighbor which is already matched so I'm
going to give up on four and leave it on
match forever five and six six again in
the imagine a paragraph as poor neighbor
so I'm going to do that now if you think
about it well each vertex will be placed
on the left or right with equal
probability and I'm gonna keep an edge
if the early vertex appear on the left
and the later verdicts appear on the
right right so basically every single
edge will be kept in the imaginary by
paragraph with property a corner which
means that after the reduction the
expected size of the optimal by pattern
matching is at least a quarter of the
original optimal matching and well
running the greedy algorithm which is
0.5 comparative with respect to the by
paragraph so when you multiply these two
together I get a 1 over 8 competive
algorithm so what happened why I get 1
over a instead of 1/4 as claimed well it
is because I'm doing something very
naive I just place the vertices like
independently and randomly on the left
and right with independently with equal
probability what they show is that
there's smart way to introduce
correlation in this process which will
improve the probability that a edge is
kept from 1/4 to 1/2 now I'm not going
to be able to get to the details of that
but that basically is where the
improvement comes from
I'm gonna skip the edge weighted case
but it's basically the same reduction
modular appropriate argument so it's a
summary on I at the beginning III hope I
have convinced you that the kbv model
failed to capture three important aspect
of right sharing problem even though
rationing is clearly a online matching
problem first of all right sharing
requires to consider none by paragraphs
and second of all it requires a model
that allow all vertices to arrive online
and today I cover two works which are
much related that come up with in a way
a model that that captured these two
aspects the first one is by my courses
and myself called fully online matching
and the key takeaway is that these
classic algorithms are including ranking
and what the feeling are still strictly
better than 0.5 competitive even in this
margin much more general fully online
model the second one is the edge way the
case which essentially the same as our
model except that they make the 500
assumption and this factor assumption
allowed them to handle the edge weighted
case and they introduced a reduction
that allow you to get a point two five
competitor our algorithm even in the
edge weighted case under the 500
assumption
I'm gonna skip some of the things that
this I do want to mention so I want to
argue that in a fully online matching
model actually ranking and what a
feeling this classic algorithm may not
be the right answer and the reason is
the following in the fully online actual
model there will be a set of vertices
that are in convenor intermediate state
where they have arrived but they have
yet to reach their deadline so in
principle I the algorithm is able to
observe the edges among these vertices
now if you think about it ranking and
what a feeling never make use of those
edges I never make use of this
information about those edges you might
as well hide that information from the
algorithm and the algorithm will just
proceed just just as fine so intuitively
this is this is leaving a very important
piece of information out of the picture
right obviously I want you know that
whether this vertex is already very well
connected has a lot of backup options as
opposed to some other vertex that has no
edge you know with any of the vertices
that has already arrived so I think it
would be super interesting to explore
now with them beyond ranking and what a
feeling in light of this intuition and
another one is that like obviously
closing this point two five and point
five gap and that actually require a
very fundamentally new idea because well
first of all edge weighted on line
matching even the kbv model is very hard
so like even after the reduction you end
up with a super difficult problem and
second of all the reduction kind of give
up half of the edges for free right and
I'm a bit uneasy with that reduction in
the sense that it's not clear to me that
that losing half of the edges for free
is necessary so I would really love to
see new ideas that will allow us to to
go beyond this point two-five ratio okay
that's all thank you
[Applause]
okay okay
yes so imagine just just imagine the
fractional problem where each vertex can
be fractionally matched to multiple
vertices let's say pointing to
professionalism actually this point
refraction is make sure that that and so
and so forth so at any point each vertex
is let partially match right so any time
where new vertex arrive I will kind of
match this one unit of the vertex bit by
bit
and each time match it to the one with
the lowest water level order that it's
the least match fractionally I just want
to be like as fair or as equal as
possible to all the neighbors like
whoever that is least match right now
I'm going to match the next bit to that
neighbor so that's actually a very major
question even in the KB model like in
the edge so for the for the unweighted
case clearly agreed is not the optimal
thing you can you can run ranking right
but for the edge weighted case then it's
a bit unclear like what you can do so
that's why I say that after the
reduction it seems that we end up with
kind of one of the major open question
in the kpv model so that's a very good
question if you come up with better
algorithm than greedy for edge where the
case that you will be able to improve
the 0.25 to something better but since
you already lose half of the edges for 3
and it's unreasonable to assume that you
can get one competitive after that so
you will never be able to go all the way
to point five it doesn't matter how
smart you are witness after the
reduction so my question was even
without improving
my mother putting these reductions on
how we coupled with an average winner is
not reading and you know just work for
this reduction it's not clear to me that
we have extra properties after the
reduction like like basically you're
asking that whether the by paragraph
that we get from this reduction it's not
really in worst case and maybe you can
you have some extra property that you
can make use of instead of like solving
the edge related case in the in the
worst case scenario I do not know the
answer for that and I I think it's
reasonable to assume that you you have
it's not completely worst case but I do
not know like a concrete property that
can state at this point in the
ride-sharing setting is so lift for
example might be able to say with high
probability someone at rush hours can
request a ride in like downtown right
right right right in if you have strong
or I guess is earthy report that says
that if you have strong prior beliefs
about what the world's what they're just
coming in are gonna look like and then
you can actually do better than the same
one minus one or III I would not
recommend taking this like numbers too
seriously and and you're definitely
right like stochastic information or
predictions of what new requests may
arrive is one important aspect that we
abstract away in this model and yeah I
really think that that would be
interesting work right that's right and
it was kind of the the most general kind
of or the weakest kind of stochastic
Hasek assumption you can make is in
light of the is similar to this random
rifle assumption that's done by the
other group and but but we are very far
from getting to a point that's
what what's known in the model yes in
the free dispose oh and that's actually
the the the the key part where I make
use of this FIFO assumption like you can
actually mimic the free disposal
behavior of the algorithm so let me let
me just like use one minute okay so like
let's say this vertex for arrived in
this graph and in light of the high
value of this edge I really want to
dispose this edge and accept this one
right I claim that I can actually do it
in the this graph and that's because
when four arrived by definition Q hasn't
left yet right and three because it has
acted with to arrive later than two so
three also hasn't left so both of these
two vertices are still in the market so
I can actually in a way revoke the
decision of this edge so basically when
I say that okay I'll pick this edge it's
the tentative decision and only at the
deadline of one of these two vertices
this decision will be finalized and then
by the FIFO assumption you can actually
mimic the free disposal behavior indeed
by hierarchies
so is there any work compared it says to
understand the value of increasing the
the windows like if you say you increase
the window by 10 percent and then
compare the online algorithm with the
increase window to be off before the
increase so it will not make sense in
the model that we have right now because
increasingly if increase in the window
does not allow extra neighbors that it
would not change the problem right okay
so it depends I think you you are
thinking about like there's some
underlying graph only based on like
where whether they're compatible in
terms of the pickup location and
destination and then maybe then it will
make sense like increase in the window
by 10 percent may give you access to
extra neighbors that will be similar to
some kind of a resource documentation in
the online matching setting sorry in
online algorithm setting again I do not
know the answer for that like right now
I'm just focused on this simplest a
cleanest mathematical model that I try
to get something yeah
[Applause]